[Music]
good morning guys today is a beautiful
Saturday morning and I am heading to
puppies and Pilates oh my god I'm so
excited for that so Cassie good friend
Blogilates a Katy Blogilates she invited
me to go do some Pilates and she's also
inviting some puppies and she was like
hey girl you want to come I'm like yes I
love puppies
so I'm all dressed I'm actually wearing
her stuff from a pop flex so these are
the leggings from her top flex line and
then there's a cute little fanny pack I
got recently this thing that I'm wearing
right now is from Lululemon Gio gave it
to me for my birthday
two years ago but then this bra thing it
was it a sports bra this is also from
pop leg it's so cute and then the whole
thing okay I can't show you right now
you just you'll see later when I'm doing
Pilates a puppy and my baby I love you
bye joke don't be jealous I'm gonna go
play with some puppies I still love you
okay look at this so Cassie you did a
collab with wet and wild
look there's a puppy already Katy this
is us Congrats Cassie look at her
fabulous look it's honey bear
[Music]
Cassy husband is that weird to hear that
you know is that weird did you get sued
now cuz it took me a minute just to it
now Congrats on everything
thank you but I mean yours what's ours
is yours is yours right
[Music]
you water bottle there's a puppy pen oh
my god that is adorable
I am honestly
I'm just
Oh
[Applause]
in arica pick the spot right in the
front there right there and they were
like hey how about you like set up right
here where Lucia is and I'm like
I'll be like one row behind I'm not good
at this business toughness of all you
guys so today we are moving to the
properties class and for those of you
who haven't seen that report
one is the pop music the matter
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
she wanted to do Pilates to get up the
entire mat for your mommy
[Applause]
my entire body is shaking right now
[Applause]
she is so good I'm always so impressed
with Cathy every time we do a classic er
the entire time she's talking and
cheering you on
while she's doing the movie
like girl you're so inspiring like I
love her so much I try to do her YouTube
videos at home too like how did she do
amazing I love her
[Applause]
adorable Eureka had to do right dripping
dripping good workout
[Applause]
you know talking the whole time oh my
God look at what cats eat game it's
their entire line for with wet and wild
Cassie this is so cool he's been so good
in the class I was dying and I love you
because now I feel like I'm ready to
just check on the rest of the year
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Kathie's dougie look at me so cute and
so well-behaved do you like the class
dude did you like the class look at how
cute this blue bandana that's so
adorable so good hey alright I'm home
now put my baby to charge every time I
do that I'm like whoa it's like I have
to charge my phone and I have to charge
my car it's so weird I am exhausted like
right now I just took off my shoes and I
started going up the stairs and I'm like
oh my goodness my legs are like just
kidding I'm exaggerating saying Kathy
got no heart cut out of me okay let's go
see what the hubby's doing hi my baby
did you miss me are you jealous I was
hanging out with a lot of puppies no you
don't care hi Maya you guys are so cute
I love how you greet me when I get home
hi oh my god that's so cute stop it oh
my god what do I live in a house that
has so many stairs Hey
I just survived a workout Kathy I can't
I think you had a really good workout
yes it was amazing it was intense and I
am dead I gotta take a shower it's not
on Tulane this beautiful made bed that
I've been making every morning making my
bed every morning look at this and I
look at my outside oh wait I have
something there but it's usually clean
it's literally one thing anyway
I'm gonna take a shower you know how I
kept trying to show you this sports bra
from the back and I failed miserably
well now there's mirrors here and I
could show you look how cute this is
so thank you bringing in this up that
guest gave me at the event but look it's
just broad so adorable pup looks like a
sea ho yeah I got a new yoga mat and as
she gave me my first ever workout towel
I've never owned a workout towel before
now I had one and then I got a whole
bunch of cool makeup to play with which
I never play with makeup but now I get
to work out makeup you know what that's
a good question
I don't know maybe you know what I think
you're right this is a workout makeup
because then there's like hit the
showers face and body cleansing wipes
like after your workout kind of stuff
dry shampoo hair mist body mist I
should've asked Cassie when I was there
okay yeah you got distracted yeah
you know what you just blew my mind
though I I just only makes sense that
this is workouts makeup stuff okay so I
opened up the bag and then it says wet
and wild pump the first at Beauty like
math like athletic beauty like so yeah
KC's right it's talking about like
anthing your beauty regimen before the
gym leaving in gym glowing this and look
at Cassie she just looks fabulous now I
can fully confirm that this is workout
makeup now I feel better about it okay
now let's see you guys tomorrow okay
morning guys it's Sunday now and I'm
heading to go pick up Christina so we
can head over to blush Khan and blush
Khan what it is it's like this
convention where Beauty people will get
together and get together and then talk
about beauty stuff so look at this what
do you think do you like my outfit just
kidding
no so I got this body chain years ago
and I've never used it ever and
with this outfit I'm like you know what
I'll bust up the body chain and I
actually did my eyeshadow and like my
makeup because you know it's a beauty
you bent I want to try to like glad
myself up a little bit more I still need
to put my shoes on but I'm gonna put
some like high-heeled boots type of
stuff and then I got this leotard thing
I think this is from fashion Nova or
something I'm not sponsored by them I
actually bought things with my own money
because I wanted to see what it was all
about and it's alright but these pants
they are from I don't remember the name
but it's a designer person that I got in
a gift bag at one of these events once I
can't make it up a good American oh I'm
gonna be wearing this jacket my brown
biker jacket this one I got from fresh
cuff so yeah that's my outfit yeah I
woke up this morning so sort happy
really beat my butt
oh man even that little chuckle my abs
hurt my butt hurts my thighs hurt my
back hurts my neck hurts
because there were some moves where I
had to do like a nap kind of workout
thing but instead of actually using my
app because I'm not used to using it I
would use my neck a lot and that really
made my night sore so I'm just like I
healed myself off of bed today
I actually was supposed to pick up
Christina an hour ago but then I was
like girlfriend I'm so sorry
I'm like struggling trying to get up
right now I'm trying to get ready
alright just got to Christina's place
and I just wanted an excuse to pull at
the camera and just you know
come on this is slow beautiful petal of
it no but honestly I wanna see her
reaction to my baby during the daytime
because she's seen it in the nighttime
before already but yeah like this is my
favorite part like look at this I don't
know if you can tell but it's all glass
and I love it sometimes I wish I could
sit in the backseat so just like soak it
all in but then I'm like no I love
driving it too and honestly I've become
a much nicer and lazier driver since
driving this car nicer because now I'm
just like enjoying the ride before I
used to be like oh just get to the
destination like I just don't want to be
stuck on the road I would just be more
of a aggressive driver and now I'm just
enjoying the ride
so hit my hair now I'm just enjoying
that right so now I'm just I don't know
I'm not so aggressive and I've become a
lazier driver because this car has so
many features so my favorite thing is
like if you hard press on the brake
it'll hold so if you're at a stop at a
stoplight or like in the drive-through
or whatever I don't have to just
continue to press the brake I can just
like I press it once and the car stops
and if I want to keep going then I just
press on the gas and it'll immediately
go so I'm much lazier that way and it
also has this smart cruise control thing
so if I'm on the street it will follow
the same speed as a car ahead of me so I
don't even have to press on the gas
anymore I'm such a lousy driver
and then on the freeway I just use the
autopilot and it literally drives itself
it's such a cool of car I just can't
stop admiring this car I'm just so in
love with it I love it so much and then
I just love the white seats to it so
maybe I was considering getting seeker
if I'm like what's the point of that
like I got this card to enjoy it right
so why get seat covers to try to print
that and then the entire time not even
fully enjoy the experience of the car so
I was like I'm not gonna do it if it
gets really really crazy bad which I
don't think it will until like many many
years from now then I'll just consider
like real pole stirring it or something
but I just I'm just gonna leave it like
this I love it ignore my jacket oh yeah
I mastered opening your door yeah yeah
nice to see you girlfriend you look good
yeah I like your outfit Thanks
I like yours too she's showing awesome
legs and said I look like a goth right
now really
I had a choker on earlier yeah like I
think that's adding to it I took it off
so oh no you're good
thank you yeah I was just telling them
that you've seen this car at nighttime I
know this sounds like guys I'm like I
want to see what do you think I like
this many colors I love your white tees
but it makes me kind of nervous about
sitting here - no I don't don't be like
it's really high-quality vegan leather
type thing I don't know I don't know
exactly what it's called but it's
high-quality so don't worry about it
dude I want this car so bad right oh my
god you should totally get it enjoying
the teeth em how you know I might I'm
just talking about it's like oh maybe
we'll see what we can do with my car I
know and it's so funny because I wanted
your car what car do you have again
Mercedes c300 yeah so I was considering
getting that car but then this one
complained also you couldn't love it if
you get it and then I'm like forget it
all right you're ready for blood
[Music]
cute
it was like the longest look ever from
the parking lot here my feet are hurting
already
I am so we just got to the backstage
area and I found a friendly organizer
permit girl you did a great job
yeah yeah and you know what honestly
thank you because of Kyla she
recommended us for the Croatia trip so
without her we wouldn't have fun the
most amazing trip of our life so think
you know I love mark we a so she also
has this blog my laude my lumping vlogs
check that out
guys taking photos of us
[Applause]
he was like hey
sure now you're getting Christina look
at her work
I love how he's telling us how to pose
too
oh goody bag
the riddle
I love free stuff in love foursome
oh my god we just thought we could get
candy
Wow
[Music]
are you challenging
she can't
[Music]
[Music]
like cute alright so I tried shaping my
intro heart but
[Applause]
[Music]
because
[Music]
[Applause]
look at this stuff is so fun
[Music]
we just missed her to be continued when
she goes back
we found for ya
I love it you guys are adorable
I picked it out
it was good
I love it no we have to leave actually
true
[Applause]
[Music]
let me okay live my blog for my blog
club we found Tommy
Tommy so tell me about the booth that's
right behind you
behind me is my girlfriend's birthday
bunch of the signs this one yo tell me
again how do you pronounce it
alright so - ah surprise
[Applause]
like a girl too
[Applause]
wait for the Train thank you so much
baby Leia oh my feet hurt goodbye all
right we're back at Christina's place
now back to the lady I know you're so
looking about baby I'm home I want a
baby I know you for bringing me up or
friend meself yeah we should do this
more often
for sure babies you know right cuz then
no more free time
[Music]
[Music]